and then I got I got to ask um obviously
the the critical reception right now you
know Metacritic was sitting at what a 96
right now I mean it is cooking
everywhere everyone's talk switch
Covenant highlights everyone's talking
that tears of the Kingdom called that
but there is
some controversy and I'm seeing the
trend a little bit on Twitter and you
know basically you know some fans feel
that
um
Nintendo Community or certain gaming
communities are not keeping the same
energy with 30 frames per second I'm
seeing 30 frames per second Trend a lot
and how on one hand with Jedi Survivor
and redfall how people were Nicki get
for the performance but they're saying
you know on the other hand these same
people again now I'm just reading what
people are saying it's not saying what
Cog said I'm just video people saying
that they don't keep the same energy
when it comes to Nintendo and they're
Nostalgia because they are still
performance issues but yet these same
reviewers are not commenting on that or
nicking the score how do you feel about
that
they're they're 100 right you know
it feels real icky to play this game in
30 frames well I will say is it's
consistent like I do feel drops every
now and then but for the most part it
doesn't give me a headache like like
Jedi Survivor sometimes is making me
nauseous I still enjoy playing it but
sometimes it did because the frame rate
was at 60 on performance mode I believe
but it was dropping so much so
frequently it never really truly felt at
60 sure this game's 30 and you know if
you if if you do the the finesse finesse
I'm not going to say it all ah you know
yeah then you know
it's
it's one of those things where you know
if Nintendo don't approve their own
Hardware
at that point uh some people just aren't
cool playing to the six uh at 30. uh I
definitely don't like playing this game
at 30 but I've always been I go where
the games are and as much as I hate
playing this game at 30. I I will go
where the games are because I can't just
play this on something else like a guy
to play it on the screen whatever
Starfield you said that you go no I'll
go on people see if there's a better
place to play it all go oh see this is
the community he's talking about they
say somehow Nintendo magically people
just forget everything about what they
said last
hmm what it was see but there's a better
place to play and first off Nintendo
will go out there acting like all the
games
so you know they need to stop that right
off the bat so you said just because
they don't say we don't expect it from
them well Nintendo doesn't come out
there and say that so look we do expect
it from them but it's different than a
company coming out their gloatings at
their plat their consoles the most
powerful platform ever made and it isn't
handling games at 60. it's different one
yeah
it's it's a different when you have a
series X and A PS5 and you're playing
the majority of games for the past two
years at 60 frames and you got this
random first party that comes to 30
frames like there is difference on this
if you want to play anything on the
switch man that's cat
matter of fact you're getting hayachi
face for that man no no what happened
that's that's all cats just doing this
because y'all like Nintendo that's all
that is switches
if a PlayStation did that or Xbox did
that y'all will take the console and
boot it across all right but okay okay
y'all know it's old Hardware y'all know
y'all was bamboozle the reason redfa got
hit the way it was is because Zelda runs
poorly but Zelda's a really good game
out there and it would have been praised
by the majority and everyone loved it
people would have overlooked the 30. it
was a 30 on top of the underwhelming
that that game did to people all right
so so what about yeah this chat is
hilarious right now all right so I get I
get what you're saying with that so so
what about it it let's use the this Jedi
argument right
people feel that Jedi Survivor is an
amazing game that has performance issues
but in the reviews of Jedi Survivor
you'll see the performance issues
wretched and that will Nick the score
down from greatness what do you say for
the Jedi father community that say yo
they don't they just like yo y'all not
applying to save energy to us because
our joint is gave it a year material but
you you as soon as you see Zelda running
around y'all taking it back to 85 and
y'all feel it what do you say about the
surviving Community I think there's a
difference between a gun running at 30
frames and a game having performance
issues okay uh you know a game could
stay to 30 and that's exactly how the
developer played it uh Jedi Survivor
came out almost broken I was following
through the map uh sometimes the scenes
wouldn't go through I remember I was
fighting someone at the end and it told
me to do uh you know the force move up
and it glitched and I couldn't do that
there was a variety of things that
happened during my experience of Jedi
survivors
on the series X
at the end of the day look this game it
should run 60 but we're not in the
reality of that uh if anything
what do you guys at that point it's like
look do I not play the game because it's
not running at six nah just give it the
proper score so there's no way it's a 10
out of ten it's not like I'm not saying
it right it's not like I'm coming out
here saying it's it's oh man this
thing's running at six it's
I mean if you're gonna start knocking
people for coming out and not doing 4K
Ace these dudes ain't doing 4K we know
what they say anything
for sure they box ain't doing that it's
just your chalk it up is a loss the
thing uh when it comes to uh the
difference between tears of your kingdom
and Jedi Survivor I will say breath of
uh tears of the Kingdom runs better you
know so it's a smooth 30. the hardest
cap I've ever seen I get that I get that
but at the same time I'm not following
through Maps I'm not getting stuck in
Aries
but kid
yo Jedi Survivor got more
in the first scene then they probably
got in the whole game all right we're
gonna do that let's throw the bricks on
the wall if the bricks on the wall ain't
looking like Nintendo 64 smoothed out
you know how they stretch the texture
yeah they stretched the texture here's
the thing
I was playing Jedi Survivor on
performance mode I felt like it ran 60
but there's a lot of times when I'm
running there's a lot of stutter I could
feel the frame rate drop into probably
40s to high 30s consistently and go
right back up to 60. those type of that
type of performance makes you get really
annoyed because it's not look out of
performance mode no it doesn't but I
don't feel that because look it might be
a it might not be at 30 the entire time
but I feel like it's more towards that
than 60 dropping to 40. you need to
offer 60 days the game just feels way
more stable and I love compare it I love
Jedi Survivor I said you should buy it
once the issues are fixed but at the end
of the day yeah
an apple is an apple also so so King it
it adds the apples the oranges it's it's
cap the cap
stop but King are in defense of of the
Zelda ain't no defending these dudes
weak limp Hardware until and everybody
got to be like yeah man it's the
greatest 96 meta score oh what about the
dips in the frame rate well you know
Nintendo
well you you know Nintendo
what about the sparse it's the sparse
environment
well you know
I know Nintendo need to get better
Hardware
you hear the thing is
I I agree with you there's there's a lot
of that going on you know but at the end
of the day in order to get that eight
thing that you talking about the
majority of people had a score to eight
or a nine all right but I don't think
that the issues have been running at 30
is is Justified taking one to two points
I do to do it to everybody else
everybody get the smoke but these dudes
immune to the Smoke
Gets all the smoke I don't care I'm not
saying that it's not a dope game it's a
dope game great smoke for you
yo nobody told you to wear those plaid
pants with that Lumberjack jacket oh
damn you don't look good baby so stop
acting like he looking stop over because
it stop overlooking the fact that
Nintendo got on high waters
is man
you're right here no I acted like
Nintendo socks you can't see Nintendo
now we can see your ankles be
so you try to say that they still
wearing some out of fashion thing and
nobody got the heart to tell them that
they got the hot waters on with their
frames and they perform it yeah
oh Dr Lee Jeans King I'm not I'm not I'm
not I'm not rocking with it I'm not
subscribing to that I'm not saying it's
not a good game right we gonna start
talking like it is an ugly duckling
we're gonna start doing that okay what's
the reason why they go cell shaded oh
it's cartoon yeah it's an artistic
Choice it's what you had to do
one thing what about people saying which
is a legit thing like yo this is 2017
Hardware now you asking 2017
Nintendo don't want to give you
something new they want to sell you
something old then they yo the result is
it is it me
or is it the resolution in the frames
the same as breath as well
why is the game ten dollars more here's
the thing
when it comes to Performance issues the
the better the game is the more people
will ignore it yes the game is extremely
good and they and they are happy and
excited and playing it more than they're
frustrated people will forget all about
that when it comes to writing their
notes
this is why I gotta fight back oh bro
here we go I've seen people online at
GameStop let's go holding the cartridge
talk about the greatest game of all time
you didn't even play it yet
you didn't even play yet stop the cap
like these dudes out here this is the
greatest
sound like a shot against your taco even
saying that I've waited for this game
since the last one my my switch I
haven't played another game since the
breath of the wild they premature
camping yeah man yo
we ain't gonna lie we ain't gonna act
like this ain't the biggest thing they
had yes
and and it's here okay I feel y'all stop
going overboard with it man
y'all ain't gotta say he look handsome
that would look handsome man you know
sometimes you see somebody bring their
baby around yo yo you see the baby and
you'd be like um that's a baby you ain't
got ta say the baby baby cute you ain't
got [__]
I touched the baby
say the baby you can just be like yo
that's a baby like that baby doing what
babies do definitely doing nobody
telling them they baby ugly you ain't
gotta tell them it's ugly though oh you
gotta act like it's cute like when it
comes to this particular game
I I do think it's good I think it's
going to get a lot of uh play at the end
of the day
if you don't want to play a dirty
fairing game I definitely understand I
hate playing them too you know wait for
them to release the switch Pro switch
switch or something like it's like I
I've told people multiple times and I'll
continue saying it I will go where the
game is I don't care what I have to play
I don't care where I gotta go if the
game is there and I want to play it I'm
going to go there and play do I like
playing this thing at 30 frames no but
what if I tell you I got an option for
you okay
what if I tell you if you go down this
Rabbit Hole
don't do that don't get us cancel take
work they'll get us canceled
I'm telling you right now I just can't
stand the hypocrisy man the hypocrisy is
banana game before take coming for you
he said all I know is the game runs at
30 frames per second leading in Game of
the Year votes is going to run away with
the award y'all need to ask you what
people like to eat I don't care about
that he can say anything he wants it's
leading everybody love so what I don't
care about that part and don't make it
it's not ugly it's ugly baby you're
supposed to beg to be with the
Metacritic people say that that game is
the best for nobody it's a much better
just lying right now it's lying it's a
hard 86 man but y'all gonna sit here no
man is Zelda they don't come out every
hour so often man it's every 10 years we
get this Haley comic coming through and
all your capping cause y'all nobody
wants to be the dude to say it's ugly
though nobody want to be like yeah that
game that you love though that's at 30
frames per second and we clown 30 frames
per second game I see the starches dudes
they'll be like I ain't gonna never play
no game that ain't no 30. this is the
next man and they cap they turn around
and say well you know the Nintendo
that's not it got that influence it's
okay are you are you implying that
Nintendo's influence and control and
Metacritic and are you saying that
people are scared to say that this game
is not Perfection imma say this
and I'm I'ma shoot
oh you review dudes they got it early
now one of y'all dudes was gonna say
anything wrong about that game
y'all was so happy
[Laughter]
that's when we do it off off she kissed
me on my cheeks all for the cold alone
you gave it a 92.
and then when it turned on and you walk
down the corridor and Zelda told the
link and said you know this Corridor is
very nice
[Laughter]
oh my God yeah okay I'll I'll have to
bend the knee on that yeah I wasn't
gonna call you out when it cut when it
comes to getting he said that Starfield
30 you ain't doing it but you was over
there with that zone well see there's
another place I can play store I respect
you can play Zelda
shout out to the Rock Ally it's a great
device it's a great device it's just at
the end of the day it's like look like
if I want to play it I'm going to play
where where I have access to it and I do
think that because Nintendo doesn't do
anything you know 21st century when they
do anything 21st century they they get
all these props you know there's
definitely no denying I got a theory oh
Lord I got it there what's the theory
there he is you guys don't buck up on
Nintendo oh no Nintendo don't care about
you no matter what you do Nintendo don't
care Nintendo said you're not gonna buy
so what
so either you buy or you leave even if
you like it or you don't that's it the
and they are the real dudes holding that
energy you're wrong about that Nintendo
says we're going to give you Game of the
Year container type games
okay when did breath of the wild come
out
2017. all right now
all these yes
to still be 30 frames